Undoubtedly one of the modern history's
most notorious and abhorrent his crimes
that the stuff of nightmares
over the course of 13 years,
he prowls for men and load them back
to his house before drugging them and
strangling them and all you took the
lives of 17 men between 1978 and 1991,
but simply killing his victims
wasn't enough for Jeffrey Dahmer.
He never wanted them to leave,
so he saved several trophies,
including severed heads.
Eventually even eight parts of the
victims don't always captured in 1991 and
sentenced to 16 lifetimes here was
killed by a fellow prison inmates,
Christopher Scarborough in 1994.
And in today's video we're taking a
look at the serial killers dark life.
Jeffrey Dahmer was born on May
the 21st 1960 in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin to Lionel,
enjoy stanhope.
He was described by his mother was a
beautiful baby and both parents considered
him to be a normal child,
but as teachers they saw them differently.
At least one.
His first grade teacher
wondered if Jeffrey was
neglected at home and noted that
he was a reserved child
on his report card.
In truth,
both of Jeffrey's parents didn't spend
a lot of time with him when Jeffrey was
young.
His father was in college earning a
chemistry degree and Jeffrey's mother was
often bedridden,
recovering from illnesses.
His parents had a tumultuous marriage
that he later described as extreme tension
from the constant arguing Italian,
yet there was no doubt Lionel and Joyce
Dahmer love their son and tried to do
the best for him when he was six years
old where I Jeffrey might not take well
to a new baby brother.
They let him pick out his name.
Jeffrey named his younger brother David.
The Donner family moved a few times
before eventually settling in bath in Ohio
in 1968.
If there were any red flags that indicated
future violence in the young Jeffrey,
it was this fascination with animal
bones and how they fit together.
The interest in caucuses began
when he was four years old.
Once a Jeffrey was helping his father,
clear animal remains from under the house,
and Jeffrey was oddly thrilled by the
sound of the boons dropping into the metal
buckets he lays.
It began collecting them,
searching in ditches and
along streets for roadkill.
He began dismembering the bodies behind
the house in a patch of wooded area,
installed the various body parts
in John's in the families woodshed.
On one occasion,
Jeffrey decapitated the corpse of a dog
before nailing the body to a tree when
he was 10 years old.
So over dinner,
Jeffrey asked his father what would happen
if chicken bones were placed in each
line or a chemist interpreted
his son's question,
is miss scientific curiosity?
And he took the opportunity to teach your
son about the proper way to clean and
to preserve his collections.
Jeffrey later admitted that the age
of 14 that he experiencing sexual
compulsion.
He designed boys,
not girls,
and these sexual fantasies
involved submission,
violence and death.
He began drinking as a
teenager to suppress his urges
and didn't talk to anyone
about the disturbing
thoughts that he was having.
At the age of 16,
he fantasized about raping a jogger.
He saw regularly and plans
to attack the man one day,
Jeffrey Land Way to the baseball bats
and the bushes along the man's regular
route.
The man didn't come by that day and
Jeffrey never attempted to carry it out
again.
I revere high school.
Most of his classmates thought of
Diana as an outcast with few friends.
Some were troubled by his heavy drinking.
They drunk both and beer
and liquor at school,
so I'm going,
it's inside the lining of his army.
Fatigue jacket,
his grades one average,
and then took a dive as his drinking
spun out of control in 1977.
He played clarinet briefly and
abandoned was a decent tennis player.
Overall,
his teachers observe Jeffrey
is a polite and quiet boy,
although he was awkward,
he regularly amused as
classmates by staging pranks
such as acting out seizures,
knocking over items,
and making loud and obnoxious noises.
The banks were so popular that similar
behavior was referred to as doing a
Dhamma by the end of
high school of parents,
troubled marriage.
She finally came to an end
after an unsuccessful attempt
at counseling in early
1978 line or moved out
of the house dominant.
Graduated in May of that same year.
A few weeks after graduation.
Dharma committed his first murder when
he picked up a hitchhiker 18 year old
Steven Marks was on his way to a rock
concert when Donna Lord him back to his
house to hang out and drink
a few beers before the show.
My now dominant lived
alone as his parents,
his house,
his mother moved out with younger
brother David while his father took up
residence at the local
motel x and diamond.
Spent a few hours together listening to
music and drinking when I was ready to
leave dominant,
didn't want him to so he struck him in
the head with a 10 pound dumbbell and
strangled him to death.
While Hicks was unconscious,
he then proceeded to
masturbate over his body,
moved him to the
crawlspace under the house,
and they selected as body before
burying it in a shallow grave.
Several weeks later,
Diana on Earth,
Texas,
body the flesh from the bones
and dissolve this an asset.
He crushed his bones with a sledge
hammer and sprinkled them in the woodlot
behind the house.
A short time later,
diamonds father visited his son and
learns that he was living alone.
He moved back into the house and
convinced to Diana to enroll in college.
Diamond spent three months at Ohio State
University before dropping out in early
of 1979 at the urging of his father,
he joined the US army dominant,
served as a combat medic in Germany,
but it's performance
deteriorated due to his drinking.
He was honorably discharged
in March of 1981,
at least two soldiers later or tested
that diamond rapes them while in the
service.
One thing that has happened repeatedly
over the course of 17 months and the
other exams that diamond drugged him
following his discharge,
Donna returned home to Ohio
state only a brief time.
He was arrested for disorderly conduct
which prompted his father to arrange for
dominance.
He lived with his grandmother in Wisconsin
is alcoholism continued and he was
arrested for indecent exposure.
He was arrested again in 1986 when to
boys' accused him of masturbating in front
of them.
In September of 1987,
Dama took his second victim
viceman with Steven to amy.
According to Donna,
he has no memory of killing to amy.
They have checked into a hotel
room together and drank heavily,
and Donald woke in the morning and
discovered the body next to him.
Dama bought a large suitcase
to transport two Emmys,
remains to his grandmother's basement,
were dismembered and
masturbated over the corpse,
so for disposing of the remains only
after dominic kills another two victims of
his grandmother's home,
did she tire of his late
nights in his drunkenness.
She had no knowledge of his
other activities and forced
them to move out of the
premises.
In 1988,
that September of 1988
Dahmer had an extremely lucky
escape and encounter with a
13 year old Laotian by resulted in
charges of sexual exploitation and second
degree sexual assault for diamond.
He pled guilty claiming that the boy
had appeared much older while awaiting
sentencing for the sexual assault case.
Dahmer again,
put his grandmother's
basement to a gruesome use.
In March of 1989,
he learned drugged,
strangled,
sodomized,
photographed,
dismembered,
and disposed of Antony caesars and
aspiring model at his trial for child
molestation.
In 1989,
Dima was the model of contrition.
He argued eloquently in his own defense
about how he had seen the error of his
ways and that his arrest marked
a turning point in his life.
His defense counsel argued
that he needed treatment,
not incarceration,
and the judge agreed handing down a one
year prison sentence on day release,
allowing dumber to work his job during
the day and to return to prison at night
as well as handing down a five
year probationary sentence.
Years later in an interview
with CNN line or dominant,
stated that he wrote a letter to the
court that issued that sentence requesting
psychological help
before his son's parole.
However,
Jeffrey Dahmer was granted
an early release by the
judge off to serving only 10
months of a sentence.
He briefly lived with his grandmother
following has released during which time
he does not appear to added to his body
counts before moving back into his own
apartment over the following years.
Dom is victim counts,
accelerated,
bringing his total from four to 17.
He developed rituals as he progressed,
experimented with mechanical
means of disposal,
and often consuming flesh of his victims.
Dama are also attempted crew to the bottom
is drilling into victim skulls while
they were still alive and injecting
them with Muriatic assets.
He was careful to select victims on
the fringes of society who were often
itinerants or borderline criminal,
making their disappearances
less noticeable and reducing
the likelihood of his
capture as the murders piled up.
Adama was still unsatisfied.
He stated later I was completely
swept along with my own compulsion.
I don't know how else to put it.
It didn't satisfy me completely,
so maybe I was thinking maybe another
one will maybe this one will and the
numbers started growing and growing
and just got out of control.
As you can see on May the 27th,
19,
91.
Dom Is Neda.
Sandra Smith called the police to report
that an Asian boy was running naked in
the streets when the police arrived,
the boy was incoherence and
they accepted the word of dimer,
a wise man living in a
largely poor African American
community that the boy was
his 19 year old lover.
In fact,
the boy was 14 years old and he was the
brother of the 14 year old teen that
Donna had previously molested the police
escorted dahmer and the boy home and
cleaning,
not wishing to become embroiled in
a homosexual domestic disturbance,
took only accustomed to
look around before leaving.
Once the police left the scene,
Donna killed the boy and proceeded with
his usual rituals are they conducted
even a basic search,
police officers would've
found the body of dominance.
Twelfth Victim Tony Hughes before he was
finally arrested on July the 22nd 1991,
he killed for more manual.
Dom is cunning.
Spree ended when he was arrested on July
the 22nd 1991 that day to Milwaukee.
Police officers picked up Tracy Edwards,
a 32 year old African American man
who was wandering the streets with a
headscarf dangling from his wrist.
They decided to investigate the man's
claims that we dude had drugged and
restrained him.
They arrived at domus apartments where
he commonly offered to get the keys for
the handcuffs.
Edwards claimed the knife dahmer had
threatened him with was in the bedroom,
and the officer went in
to corroborate the story.
He noticed a polaroid photographs
of dismembered bodies lying around.
It was at that point that Donna
was subdued by the officers.
Subsequent searches revealed
a heads in the refrigerator,
three more in the freezer and the catalog
of other horrors including preserved
skulls.
John's containing jenise Eylea and an
extensive gallery of macabre polaroid
photographs if its victims.
Dom is refrigerator and
polaroid photographs became
inextricably associated with
his notorious killing spree.
In 1996 following dominance death,
a group of Milwaukee businessman raised
more than $400,000 to purchase the items
that he used for his victims,
including blades,
source,
handcuffs,
and a refrigerator to
store the body parts.
They promptly destroyed them in an effort
to distance the city from the horrors
of dom,
his actions,
and the ensuing media circus
that surrounded his trial.
Jeffrey dom is trial
began in January of 1992,
given that the majority of dominance
victims were African American.
There were considerable racial tensions
and say strict security precautions were
taken,
including an eight foot
barrier of bulletproof glass
that separated him from the
gallery.
The inclusion of only one African American
on the jury provoked further unrest,
but was ultimately contains.
It's very short lived well.
I know Donna and to second wife attended
the trial throughout dahmer initially
pled not guilty to all charges despite
having confessed to the killings during
police interrogation,
but he eventually changed his plea
to guilty by virtue of insanity.
His defense then offered the gruesome
details of his behavior as proof that only
someone truly insane which
commit assumption terrible acts.
Donna later said in an interview,
it's hard for me to believe that a human
being could have done what I've done,
but I know that I did it.
The jury chose to believe
the prosecutions of sessions,
that dom was fully aware that his acts
were evil and that he chose to commit
them anyway.
On February the 15th,
19,
92,
they returned after approximately 10
hours deliberation to find him guilty but
sane on all accounts.
He was sentenced to 15 consecutive
lifetimes in prison with 16th,
10 tacked on in May.
It is now over.
This has never been the
case of trying to get free.
I didn't ever want freedom,
but this was a case to tell the
world that I did what I did,
but not for reasons of hate.
I hated no one.
I knew I was sick or evil or both.
Now I believe I was sick.
The doctors have told me about my
sickness and now I have some peace.
I know how much high of cost.
Thank God.
There will be no more harm that I can do.
I believe that I the Lord Jesus
Christ can save me from my sins.
I ask for no consideration.
Dominant reportedly adjusted
well to prison life,
although he was initially kept
apart from the general population.
He eventually convinced the authorities
to allow him to integrate more fully
with the other inmates.
He found religion in the form of books
and photos sent to him by his father and
he was granted permission by the
Columbia Correctional Institution to be
baptized by a local pastor
on November the 28th,
19,
94 in accordance with this
inclusion in regular work details.
Donna was assigned to work with
two other convicted murderers,
Jesse Anderson and Christopher Askava
after they had been left alone to complete
that task sconce or tend to find the
discover had brutally beaten both men with
a metal bar from the prison white room.
Donald was pronounced debt
after approximately an hour
and just succumbed to his
injuries days later in 2015.
Christopher Scott spoke to the New York
Post about his reasons for killing.
Donna discover alleged that he was
disturbed and not only buy diamonds crimes
but by our habits.
Donna had developed of fashioning severed
limbs from prison food to antagonize
other inmates after being taunted by
Dahmer and Anderson during their work
detail.
Scholar said that he confronted her about
his crimes before beating the two men
to death.
He also claims that the prison guards
allowed the merger to happen and dom is
will.
He requested that upon his death his
body be cremated as soon as possible,
but some medical researches wanted
just brain preserved so that it can be
studied.
Lionel Dahmer wanted to respect his
son's wishes and cremate or remains.
His mother felt his brain
should go to research.
The two parents went to court
and the judge sided with Lionel.
After one year,
diamonds body was released and the
remains were cremated as he requested in
August of 2012,
nearly two decades after his death.
It was reported that his
childhood home and Botha,
Ohio,
where he committed his first murder in
1978 and buried his victims remains was
on the markets.
It's owner,
musician Chris Butler stated that the
property would make a great time as long
as the buyer could get past the
horror facts act in March of 2016,
Butler put the house up for rent for
$8,000 for the week of the Republican
National Convention as of July 2017.
The house was no longer listed on
the market according to Zillow,
so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time.
Every Monday and Thursday
we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
suffering from the archive
over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.